sheriff's office
good morning so what's going on
my wife took money from my truck i got
25 000 missing over there i got 50 000
missing from my safe i got another
little purse i carry with smaller change
missing two thousand dollars what was
the money from
from my business okay so it's questions
well because if it's your personal money
then she's your wife then it would be
both yours but if it's business money
then it's separate that's why i have to
ask where the money came from
so from the business okay
she drank last night okay
i wonder i can't have it when was the
last time you seen the cash with cash
right no it's a chocolate kisses yeah
i don't know why you've attituded i have
to do an investigation i'm here to help
you i just need answers number one you
guys are in cso i already have real hard
trust issues with that organization with
the way you guys function operating
things like that so it's already very
difficult for me to call you guys okay
okay right now this hasn't got nothing
to do with the commission or anything it
doesn't all right 100 percent so you
guys already have your own reputations
right
so what was that
guys yeah it was cash okay when was the
last time you've seen the cash 2 20 22
because i write down notes and stuff
like that so on february 22nd
you saw the cash
the second
february 2 22. so february 2nd yeah
no i wrote down because i counted all my
money okay did an allocation know where
all my cash is okay
all right
and you said there was 25 000 missing 50
50. total because you said there was
others the difference is in there oh so
i had 90 over there i got 50 missing
okay where was the cash when it went
missing was it an account or just am i
safe it was in the safe does your wife
have access to the safe i mean i have
one key and the key is always with me
okay oh no go ahead and have them come
down in
how about you hey